I've got my [ __ ] in the right
perspective and you just go like once
you realize it's all gravy it gets real
easy yo yo
it's Gary Vee what's up G how are you
man I really appreciate that I've been
doing good man I'm building a brand and
I'm watching the show really appreciate
the hustle that you're good that you put
in and the extent to which this is what
gets me man the detail in which you
document your life it's the most amazing
thing I love half Gary Vee but it for me
daily V is Filippis cuz that's where the
rubber meets the road
stoppable
[Music]
they're gonna try to freeze you wait you
eat enough they gonna hold you back is
Dan keeping up but you never let me
never let her me but you never let me
got me a tour but there's a reason they
go there from a business standpoint and
look I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do
anything that I don't believe in and I'm
not any word area I'm just trying to
figure out how I want to do this to make
a Schwinn I know what I mean all you
know is right for me but you don't live
my life sorry about you know there's two
sides of every coin it's grass is
greener right you go one way and you get
one result you go the other way you get
another result you know what I mean
and so just you know and that's why I'm
always trying to do things in some weird
clone or things of that nature because
if you're trying to find the Hat right
these things are so cliche you know
what's amazing about this stuff Eric
from a businessman step point is these
things are all [ __ ] cliche they're
either you know they're either A or B
and if you're auntie Mary Rose I call
[ __ ] B's awesome and better and I wish
and if you're on Team B like [ __ ] you
know so I get it I'm just trying to hack
it through you know God saw it's the
biggest thing I have to unwind
I like pounded my chest and like took
off my shirt and I'm like arith or smart
and scratte it like I [ __ ] the whole
thing up but I'm excited to fix it I
just had a call with Eric Fuller who
runs the London office vaynermedia
London super excited about blowing out
vaynermedia London's business next year
really excited about that we've got the
fortune 50 companies but really looking
forward to getting some of these kind of
like thirty to fifty thousand pound a
month clients in UK so looking for that
action
recording some right hooks for the
podcast cool let's do it and start out
with check out the Facebook / hey guys
thank you so much for listening to
today's podcast also wanted to tell you
guys about my new youtube channel
youtube.com / gary vaynerchuck gary vee
youtube channel is the dailyvee monday
through friday gary vaynerchuck is where
I'm putting my keynotes business Clips
not sure this is the right strategy make
close Gary Vaynerchuk one day and put it
all back in one channel but for now this
is what I'm doing go check it out -
remember don't listen what I'm saying
watch what I'm doing so hopefully could
bring some value for some of you guys
out of this hey guys today's a weird day
there's the meetings a little blurry but
like basically client client client
client internal internal internal
something I can't share with you mainly
client client clients interesting week
for for the vlog because it's just a lot
of stuff that I can't show but obviously
just heard the running call fun for you
guys to see how I manage other offices
just saw me jamming on the podcast I'm
super excited about it if you're if
you're a fan of this vlog please get on
my podcast I'm bringing real [ __ ]
fire there and and you know I had a
really interesting talk last night at
Bloomberg have you thought about
monetizing your voice that's incredible
and it said go and also going to work
Yom Kippur is coming tonight so no
eating for me which is normal [ __ ] this
food and so my merry way
oh really really excited about the Jets
Jacksonville game this weekend you'll be
watching this after the fact and so my
prediction is Jags 23 Jeff 16 see ya and
the chit's minutes 23 to 20 so YouTube
this is basically how we write articles
this very handsome man Colin C squared
on cam takes the the umph from a talk or
a piece of content somewhere and he
follows up with some questions I answer
them turns it the first person to where
we go
a great story to me a great story
invokes a reaction the end you know it's
kind of like surprise and delight it's
like the flowers today babban is some so
it's like the flowers there they were
unexpected today but if today was
Valentine's Day they'd be a little bit
more expected so you're hacking the norm
in Hollywood you're making a two-hour
thing that's gonna be played on a big
screen in a theater right or in you know
and that's the room in social it's
something that somebody's gonna watch in
their phone while they're in the subway
eating a [ __ ] burrito like you got to
think about them differently you know
how much is a big movie cost now good
spending three hundred million dollars
if you make back nine hundred million
dollars it's a good idea they're just
spending a hundred eighty thousand to
make back forty thousands a bad idea
which is why for most of us who are JJ
and have those budgets I think we should
be smart about how much we spend and
build up you know just [ __ ]
practicality but the value is you know
captive audience for three four three
hours that's going to spend sixteen
dollars a head you know and buy
ancillary [ __ ] t-shirts and buy
[ __ ] mugs and I got a [ __ ] shoe
Baca mug here somewhere I don't know
like this is the answer to why you spend
that kind of money because when you
spend making little pieces of content
you can sell this which is great which
is great but when you do it right and
you spend a hundred million dollars ten
times over and you make this there's a
brilliant of these souls a good trillion
dollars right you know it's bigger bets
bigger wins being in losses and it's
about the practicality of it so there's
a huge ROI I mean if you make where's
the beef or just do it or MasterCard
priceless
it's [ __ ] game-changing the problem
is ninety nine percent don't and they
waste real [ __ ] money and my big
thing is like do this now I'm in a
position to make bigger bets we can
actually now like it's crazy to me that
I'm about to say we could all have an
off site again couple episodes ago check
it out
[Music]
maybe in that all say we're like let's
make a $200,000 documentary we can do
that now but I couldn't do it before so
nice to meet you how are things
Oh [ __ ] and play on metrics because
I'm not gonna if you know my family
business in Millburn
my likes my dislikes my fights and my
strokers my cold night internation sorry
wrong okay Romi I love her she's been
here about four years five brazen
changed four years and change see I'm on
my [ __ ] I mean I've been working on a
secret project
there's nobody in vaynermedia that even
knows what I'm about to tell you about
but I'm super excited about it and I
want my Facebook and my LinkedIn and my
email list and my super phone and all
those to get this first so a lot of you
have heard about the four DS thing where
you come in and you get you learn how to
really do what we do here at vaynermedia
it's a little bit different I'm obsessed
with the concept of which is what Romi
and I are working on which is really
this thesis of how do you make people
obsessed with like why is avocado toast
happening if you're a farmer right now
of a cranberry juice you want to make
your cranberry juice bigger but what if
you got all of the America to care about
cranberry juice and then you felt the
effects you hope you hear me talking
about culture hacking we have produced
two products process when you leave
there's nothing that we know that you
don't get at the end of these ten hours
and unlike any other video I made we
were finishing the touches on actually
pricing this [ __ ] so you don't even know
the price right now but I'm sure in this
email and in the Facebook post and when
you altima we click sign me up the
information will be there shortly I'll
see you soon
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 267 of the
askgaryvee show that's 10 sep 7 my have
a wonderful guest we we just finally got
to meet in real life his energy is legit
so excited for you my friend our squared
is I'm gonna call you from my standpoint
it's a at a macro everyday at a macro I
care about what the end consumer gives a
[ __ ] about when I get to the execution
of something it's a little bit more
micro it's a little bit more about me I
know that mobile video matters at a
macro right but when I make the content
it's about what's artistic and creative
for me to make
I'm just understanding what the pillars
of conversation in culture and the
places they consume that content are and
so at a macro BEM that a micro me put a
blog good-day 336 heading into another
client meeting pretty productive we've
got a little bit more out of today than
we thought we would a lot of good stuff
so I'm pretty good about that hope you
can join the blog I'm enjoying your
comments please leave a comment in the
YouTube section please pass on the
subscription this is the call to action
to pass on the subscription which one
homie which one friend which one parent
mentor
[Music]
before they get styles may the force be
with me gods or keep them shut [ __ ]
shoe baka mug here somewhere this is the
answer to why you spend that kind of
money